today's money watch this morning we're
looking at the hot housing market in the
sowing prices of homes the median new
home price in november was more than 400
thousand dollars and more than 350 000
for existing homes cbs news business
analyst jill schlesinger joins us right
now good morning jill how are you doing
what are you calling now you're doing
well please don't ask me to wait yeah
exactly and don't don't wait let me
weigh in about underwear on this segment
please
we'll talk to you during the commercial
break about that and you're right gail i
call her dollar dollar jill y'all
because she helps to save our dollars
now listen we'll get to the the housing
market in a minute but the government
they just released new data about rising
prices what can you tell us about that
and also should we be worried
well unfortunately inflation is with us
we all know it we see it every day food
energy pretty much everything in fact
the consumer price index up seven
percent from a year ago that is the
hottest pace of inflation since june of
1982.
so this is not great news for consumers
i think the better news is that the
federal reserve completely is on top of
this six 12 months ago they were telling
us this is temporary we shouldn't worry
now they're worried they are likely to
raise short-term interest rates as soon
as their march meeting so we'll likely
see at least four quarter-point
increases this year but yesterday jerome
powell testified before congress and you
know what he said he's like hey if we
have to go faster we will and i think
this is really a warning sign to the fed
to get moving
jill the housing market has been hot for
over a year now
big supply of homes which there isn't
but there is a high demand for home
buyers is that starting to change
well look i mean the housing market has
really shown huge gains in both activity
and prices we know that but you're right
it is a supply issue if you look at this
uh the number of existing homes that's
houses that are already been built right
that are for sale that inventory is down
13.3 percent from a year ago that means
that a typical house in november sold
are you ready for this in 18 days 83
percent of homes sold within a month so
this is a hot market still it is
starting to taper off a little bit so we
are expecting prices to ease off a
little bit and activity is going to
continue to ease off this year
yeah let's talk about the prices jill
because you know the the statistics show
that the price the average price of a
new home is 400 000
that's also the price of the existing
homes which seems very high to me why do
you think it is so high well number one
is it high is that a high price
well listen it's hot we're in a hot
housing market that is starting to taper
off but it is still very difficult to
find a house again it's that supply
issue but it's also demand obviously if
you look at the activity numbers and we
look at the year 2020 we came into the
year before covid with not that many
houses on the market and not that how
many houses being built then there's
this huge surge of demand not a lot of
supply and boom you have high prices
unfortunately if you're looking for a
house i don't think that condition is
going to actually change anytime soon
but we are seeing prices start to slow
down just a little bit as more homes
come on the market and also as mortgage
rates start to creep up
jill would you warn people against a
possible bubble when it comes to the
housing market when i hear about average
prices being at 400 thousand dollars
that is a lot that's not that's a lot
for the average earner for sure uh could
it go down and go down fast
well i think that the when you hear
these price increase numbers it's very
easy to take ourselves back to the mid
2000s and freak ourselves out i don't
think we need to be as concerned simply
because if you look at that period of
time there were people getting loans
with no income no documentation huge
amount of borrowed money to bet on the
housing market today we're actually
seeing a large portion of all cash
transactions in fact borrowed borrowers
are finding that they really are in back
of those all cash transactions so i
think that there's a frenzy that is
based on supply and demand but it's not
piled on high with all that borrowing or
leverage
jails should those who are thinking
about selling their home act right now
this is so difficult because when i
think of people who contact me on my
podcast and they say well i really want
to sell my house but and the butt is
there's no place to go you've got to
still find another house to buy if you
want to and a lot of people who have
tons of money that's locked away in
their homes they're uncomfortable
renting conversely if you're someone in
your starter home and you're thinking
about moving up maybe you can't find a
house and more importantly you might
have that ultra low mortgage rate that
you don't want to give up
good point i like that point starter
home what should you consider how do you
know what's affordable for your family
just give us two quick tips oh
uh run the numbers don't forget
maintenance don't forget closing costs
and never forgo an engineer's report
please
oh
that's great advice good advice closing
costs
yes it will get in trouble will be a
starter husband too all right joe thank
you very much